This is an I-Heart podcast. Guaranteed Human. Hey, what's good, y'all? You're listening to Learn the Hardway with your favorite therapist and host Kear Games. This space is about black men's experiences, having honest conversations that it's really not safe to have anywhere, but you're having them with a licensed professional who knows what he's doing. How many men carry a suit or armor. It signals to the world that you not to be played with. And just because you have the capability that does not mean that you need to, listen to learn.
这是一个I-Heart播客。百分之百真人保证。嘿，大家好，最近怎么样？欢迎收听由你最喜欢的治疗师兼主持人克尔·加姆斯（Kear Games）带来的《艰难求生》（Learn the Hardway）。这个空间探讨黑人男性的经历，进行在任何其他地方都不太安全的坦诚对话，但你是在和一个懂行的有证专业人士进行交流。有多少男人背负着铠甲？它向世界传达出你不是好惹的信号。仅仅因为你有这种能力，并不意味着你需要这么做，请在
the hard way on the IHard radio app, Apple Podcasts, or wherever you get your podcast. 2%. That's the number of people who take the stairs when there is also an escalator available. I'm Michael Easter. I'm on my podcast, 2%. I break down the science of mental toughness, fitness, and building resilience in our strange modern world. Put yourself through some hardships, and you will come out on the other side a happier,
IHeart电台App、苹果播客或你获取播客的任何地方收听《艰难求生》。2%。这是当旁边有自动扶梯可用时，仍选择走楼梯的人的比例。我是迈克尔·伊斯瑟（Michael Easter）。在我的播客《2%》中，我将剖析我们这个奇异现代世界中精神韧性、体能训练和培养恢复力的科学。让自己经历一些艰难困苦，你就会在另一端成为一个更快乐、
more fulfilled, healthier person. Listen to 2%. That's TWO% on the IHeartRadio app, Apple Podcasts, or wherever you get your podcasts. When a group of women discover they've all dated the same prolific con artist, they take matters into their own hands. I vowed. I will be his last target. He is not going to get away with this. He's going to get what he deserves. We always say that trust your girlfriends.
更充实、更健康的人。请在IHeartRadio应用、Apple Podcasts或任何你收听播客的地方收听《2%》。当一群女性发现她们都曾与同一个多产的骗子约会过时，她们决定自己采取行动。我发誓，我将成为他的最后一个目标。他休想就此逃脱。他会得到应有的下场。我们总是说，要相信你的闺蜜。
Listen to the girlfriends. Trust me, babe, on the Iheart radio app, Apple Podcasts, or wherever you get your podcasts. On the Look Back at it podcast. From 1979, that was a big moment for me. 84 is big to me. I'm Sam J. And I'm Alex English. Each episode, we pick a year, unpack what went down, and try to make sense of how we survived it.
在Iheart电台App、苹果播客或任何你获取播客的地方收听《相信闺蜜，相信我，宝贝》。在《回顾过去》（Look Back at It）播客中。从1979年开始，对当时的我是个重大时刻。84年对我也很重要。我是萨姆·J。我是亚历克斯·英格利士。每一集，我们都会挑选一个年份，剖析当时发生的事情，并试着理解我们是怎么熬过来的。
With our friends, fellow comedians, and favorite authors. Like Mark Lamont Hill on the 80s. 84 was a wild year. It was a wild year. I don't think there's a more important year for black people. Listen to look back at it on the IHeartRadio app, Apple Podcasts, or wherever you get your podcasts. Hello everybody. I'm Jemma Spake and welcome back to the psychology of your 20s, the podcast where we talk through the biggest changes, moments and transitions of our 20s and what they mean for our psychology. Hello everybody. Welcome back to the show. Welcome back to the podcast. It is so great to have you here. Let me ask you something.
和我们的朋友、同为喜剧演员的同行以及最喜爱的作家们一起。比如马克·拉蒙特·希尔（Mark Lamont Hill）谈80年代。1984年是疯狂的一年。那真是疯狂的一年。我认为没有哪个年份对黑人来说更重要了。在IHeartRadio应用、Apple Podcasts或任何你获取播客的地方收听《回顾过去》。大家好。我是杰玛·斯派克（Jemma Spake），欢迎回到《你二十岁的心理学》（The Psychology of Your 20s），这是一个带你探讨二十岁时最大的人生转变、时刻以及过渡，并了解它们对我们心理意味着什么的播客。大家好。欢迎回到节目中。欢迎回到本播客。很高兴你能来到这里。我问你个问题，
have you ever sat down to rest, like genuinely rest? And within minutes, you've just felt this like dreaded sense of guilt creeping in. Not boredom, not like, oh, I should probably do the dishes. I mean like this sense of like I'm doing something wrong. Like, I have broken a rule here. I have stolen time. I have stolen something I haven't paid for. What makes this so confusing?
你有没有过这样的经历：坐下来休息，比如真正的休息？然后在几分钟之内，你就会感觉到那种可怕的内疚感悄然袭来。不是无聊，不是那种“哦，我大概该去洗碗了”的感觉。我是指那种觉得自己好像在做错事的感觉。就像，我在这里打破了一条规则。我偷了时间。我偷了没有付过费的东西。是什么让这件事变得如此令人困惑？
Because I know this is something a lot of us. experience is like rest is one of the most basic human needs we have. Your brain and your body require a recovery time to function normally. Like just like you don't deserve food or you like don't deserve water. Like you need it. You don't earn or deserve rest either. You need that too. So why does something so necessary feel so difficult to access without guilt? That is what we're going to get in today. I also want to talk about this idea that laziness might not even exist as we know it. And all psychological and the social processes that have conditioned us into thinking self-worth equals output. And busyness equals value. Because your guilt around resting
因为我知道这是我们许多人都经历过的事。休息是我们拥有的最基本的人类需求之一。你的大脑和身体需要恢复时间来正常运作。就像你不需要“配不配”吃食物或喝水一样。你需要它们。你不需要赚取或配得上休息，你也需要它。那么为什么如此必要的事情，在没有内疚感的情况下却感觉如此难以企及？这就是我们今天要探讨的内容。我还想讨论这样一种观点：正如我们所知的那样，懒惰可能根本不存在。以及所有那些让我们将自我价值等同于产出、将忙碌等同于价值的心理和社会过程。因为你对休息产生的内疚感
is not a personal issue. It's actually, it's not that you're doing anything wrong. It's, there is like some crazy, fascinating historical social cultural shifts that. I'm going to walk us through today to explain why it is that when you take the day off, when you use your sick leave, when you don't do your grocery shopping straight away, you feel so bad. So without further ado, let's jump into it. My problem with guilt-free rest, I think, became very apparent this month. I was on a holiday with my family. This is like dream holiday, right? We're in Stockholm. We're in Finland. We're in Norway. it's my mom's 60th birthday like amazing mom shout out to melinda and throughout this trip i would have this
并不是个人问题。实际上，并不是你做错了什么。而是有一些疯狂、迷人的历史社会文化变迁，我今天要带大家梳理一下，来解释为什么当你请假一天、使用病假、没有立刻去买杂货时，你会觉得如此糟糕。废话不多说，让我们直接切入正题。我对无罪恶感休息的问题，我想在本月变得非常明显。我和家人一起去度假。这简直是梦想中的假期，对吧？我们在斯德哥尔摩。我们在芬兰。我们在诺威。这是我妈妈的60岁生日，超级棒的妈妈，向梅琳达（Melinda）致敬。在整个旅行中，我经常有这种
urge often around 3 p.m to go back to our hotel go back to our Airbnb go back to wherever and work and like i'm gonna mean i even did it a few times like i was like i made an excuse and i went home to work and my family was a little bit like what the fuck jemma like you're not you're not saving lives Like nobody urgently needs an Instagram post at 4 p.m. on a Saturday. Nobody needs an updated episode description at 9 p.m. on a Monday. But it was this impulse. I couldn't settle for the day until I'd done something productive. Like this terrible itch that wasn't leaving.
冲动，通常在下午3点左右，想回我们的酒店，回我们的Airbnb，回任何地方去工作。我的意思是，我甚至真的这么做了好几次。我找了个借口回家工作，而我的家人有点像：“操，杰玛，你又不是在拯救生命。”没人急着在周六下午4点发Instagram贴文。没人需要在周一晚上9点更新剧集简介。但这是一种冲动。在做点产出之前，我一整天都无法安心。就像那种挥之不去的糟糕痒感。
I think younger me would have been very quick to tell you that like I just really like working hard and I love to work. And it's like in my DNA. but I didn't particularly like not being there for family events. And I didn't particularly like feeling like I was missing out or not making memories. So why was I doing it? That's, I think, always a question we have to ask ourselves at different points. At points like this, like, why do we do things we don't want to do when we don't have to? Why do we feel like we have to?
我想年轻时的我会很快告诉你，我只是真的很努力工作，我热爱工作。这就像写在我的DNA里一样。但我其实并不喜欢缺席家庭活动。我也不喜欢那种感觉自己错过了或者没能创造回忆的感觉。那么我为什么要这么做呢？我想，这是我们在不同的人生阶段必须不断问自己的问题。在像这样的时候，为什么我们在不必这样做的时候，还要去做那些我们不想做的事？为什么我们觉得非做不可？
So let's start by discussing what's going on here. Firstly, what is our cultural obsession with productivity? because this is like, this here is the root cause. One of the biggest reasons why and how rest became this luxury of this thing to feel guilty about, basically I think happened when time stopped being something that we moved through and we experienced, and it started being something that you spent and you used. For most of human history, daily life was, you know, largely organized around tasks, seasons, sunlight, community, natural rhythms, work and productivity, like, expanded and kind of lessened
所以让我们从讨论这里究竟发生了什么开始。首先，我们对生产力的文化痴迷是什么？因为这就是根本原因。为什么以及如何让休息变成一种奢侈品、一种会让人感到内疚的事情，其中一个最大的原因，基本上我认为发生在时间不再是我们经历和度过的过程，而是变成了你花费和使用之物的时候。对于人类历史的大部分时间来说，日常生活在很大程度上是围绕着任务、季节、阳光、社区、自然规律来组织的。工作和生产力会根据
based on what the community needed and the season. If your needs were fulfilled, you rested. There was no guilt attached to that. Guilt we have to remember is a social, but more importantly, moral emotion. It derives mainly from social attitudes or other people kind of telling you you're doing something wrong. It doesn't just come up naturally without social influence or narratives about good and bad. So what exactly from then to now has changed in our social attitude? We have to fast forward to the Industrial Revolution, mainly, and this is so interesting to think about when clocks started to enter the workplace. Feels weird to say, but honestly, that was a major shift. The historian, E.P. Thompson, he wrote about this in a very close,
社区的需求和季节进行扩展或缩减。如果你的需求得到了满足，你就休息。这其中没有任何负罪感。我们必须记住，内疚是一种社会的，但更重要的是道德的情绪。它主要源于社会态度或其他人告诉你做错了事。如果没有社会影响或关于对与错的叙事，它不会凭空自然产生。那么，从那时到今天，我们的社会态度究竟发生了什么变化？我们必须快进到工业革命时期，主要是这样。思考当钟表开始进入工作场所时，这是一件非常有趣的事情。说出来感觉有点怪，但老实说，那是一个重大的转变。历史学家E.P.汤姆森在一篇非常严谨的
classic piece on industrial capitalism. It's this very famous paper and he basically says when clocks were introduced into factories and into workplaces, that is when stuff went downhill. They were used to enforce discipline. They were used to enforce higher output to basically coordinate the movements of the workers and the machines, but also to keep track of how many hours somebody was being paid for rather than output. Lateness, idleness, they were then treated as an economic problem. Like if you were late for work, you are just late for work because, you know, somebody was sick.
关于工业资本主义的经典著作中写过这一点。这是一篇非常著名的论文，他基本上指出，当钟表被引入工厂和工作场所时，事情就开始走下坡路了。它们被用来强制执行纪律。它们被用来强制实现更高产出，以协调工人和机器的动作，同时也是为了记录某人被支付了多少小时的薪水，而不是看最终产出。迟到、懒散，随后被当作经济问题来处理。如果你上班迟到，你就是上班迟到，因为（你知道的）有人生病了。
Like that was a productivity issue. There was money being lost based on your choices. Once time is measured in that way, we basically as a society begin to learn that there is always some kind of cost to rest or to not working. That, you know, that's time not being spent properly. And we might lose out if we're not on the goal. all the time. There is kind of a further social cultural element to that, to why we panic with not being busy enough or occupied by tasks. And I think that element is that not being busy
那是一个生产力问题。根据你的选择，金钱正在流失。一旦时间以这种方式被衡量，我们作为社会基本上开始了解到，休息或不工作总是伴随着某种代价。那就是，那些时间没有被好好利用。如果我们没有始终盯着目标，我们可能会有所损失。这背后还有进一步的社会文化因素，解释了为什么我们会在不够忙碌或没有被任务占据时感到恐慌。我认为这个因素是，不忙碌
means we could be out of a job, means that there isn't enough work to go around, means that you are not worth the cost to an employer. Actually, you know, looking back culturally, if you lost out on work, if you chose not to work, like, you would generally viewed pretty harshly. You were stigmatized for not doing so and you would suffer like your family wouldn't eat. There wasn't as much social security. So on a huge scale, and I know this is a psychology podcast, but to get historical, like this, our entire structure towards work and productivity and perceive responsibility shifted. It shifted from doing what was needed to doing everything in excess and what was required from you. And suddenly it's also the individual's problem if work is not
意味着我们可能会失业，意味着没有足够的工作可做，意味着你对雇主来说不值得这个成本。事实上，回顾文化历史，如果你失去了工作，如果你选择不工作，人们通常会对你产生相当严厉的看法。你会因为不这样做而遭到污名化，并且你会遭受痛苦，你的家人会吃不饱饭。当时并没有那么多的社会保障。因此，在宏观层面上——我知道这是一个心理学播客，但如果从历史角度来看——我们对工作、生产力和感知责任的整个结构发生了转变。它从做需要做的事，转变为了竭尽所能以及对你的全部要求。突然之间，如果没有完成工作
being done and money is not being made. Like that's a stressful burden. If we move forward to modern day, you know, we now have unions, we have more adequate workers' rights in a lot of countries. You know, a lot of places have weekends off. Holiday pay is another example. But what we now have that wasn't around back there and that is still contributing to this is online platforms like LinkedIn and social media, and they are a huge contributor to why you feel bad about resting. What do we do when we have five minutes in between meetings, five minutes in between appointments, five minutes whilst our pastor boils? We pick up our phones and we scroll. And in that moment, we can potentially see dozens of other people doing more than us. And this creates competition with how we use our time. And where
且没有赚到钱，这也成了个人的问题。这是一种压力沉重的负担。如果我们快进到现代，你知道的，我们现在有了工会，在许多国家我们有了更完善的劳工权益。许多地方有周末休息。带薪假期是另一个例子。但我们现在拥有、而当时没有、并且仍然在促成这种现象的是像领英（LinkedIn）和社交媒体这样的在线平台，它们是让你对休息感到内疚的巨大推论。我们在会议间隙的五分钟、预约之间的五分钟、水烧开时的五分钟里会做些什么？我们拿起手机开始刷屏。在那一刻，我们可能会看到几十个其他人做得比我们更多。这就对我们如何使用时间形成了竞争。而在
there is competition, you know, there are winners and there are losers. There are people with greater status and people with lower status. I think I need, I'm going to explain this a little bit better. More so than ever, busyness psychologically has become a status simple. There is research suggesting that in the US in particular, social perception is such that being busy and having little leisure time now means that you were important. It used to me that mean that the more leisure time you had the less, like the more important you were basically because you could afford to not work. Now it shows that you're in demand, that you're needed. Being busy is the equivalent to having a designer handbag or a BMW. Longer hours, less free time. Again, it conveys
存在竞争的地方，你知道的，就会有赢家和输家。会有地位更高的人和地位更低的人。我想我需要、我将更好地解释这一点。与以往相比，忙碌在心理上已经成了一种地位象征。有研究表明，尤其是在美国，社会观念是这样的：忙碌且几乎没有闲暇时间，现在意味着你很重要。过去，这意味着你拥有的闲暇时间越多，你就越重要，基本上是因为你负担得起不工作的开销。现在它表明你很抢手，你被需要。忙碌等同于拥有一个设计师手袋或宝马汽车。更长的工作时间，更少的自由时间。同样，它传达了
social importance. This is as twisted as it sounds because it's like, only a particular kind of busyness, right? There's only a particular kind of grind and hustle that's glamorized. People working three jobs to support their kids. People doing 14-hour factory shifts. Like, that is not glamorized the way that a CEO jet sitting around the country is. So nowadays, like, we have this shift and your phone is constantly showing that narrative directly into your face and into your life at all times, even if you don't think that it is, even if you think you're not picking up on this message, even when you're not actively thinking that you're comparing yourself to others online, your brain is naturally going to do it. Your brain is
社会重要性。这听起来非常扭曲，因为只有特定的一种忙碌，对吧？只有特定的一种拼搏和内卷被美化了。为了养活孩子而打三份工的人。在工厂做14小时轮班的人。这些人并没有像那些满世界飞的CEO那样被美化。所以现在，我们有了这种转变，你的手机无论如何都在把这种叙事直接展现在你的面孔和生活中，即使你认为没有，即使你觉得自己没有注意到这个信息，即使你没有积极地认为自己正在网上与他人进行比较，你的大脑也会自然而然地这么做。你的大脑在
collecting information on those who are achieving, the image, their progress, the praise they're getting, and what is considered impressive right now. And this influences your self-perception and therefore your attitude towards rest. Even if you're not someone who thinks of yourself as competitive, modern life is set up in a way that pushes you into competition even when you didn't really choose to be there. That is what is happening. So let's switch gears here for a second.
收集那些正在取得成就的人的信息、他们的形象、他们的进展、他们获得的赞誉，以及现在被认为令人印象深刻的内容。这会影响你的自我认知，从而影响你对休息的态度。即使你认为自己不是一个好胜的人，现代生活的设定方式也会将你推向竞争，即使你并没有真正选择身处其中。这就是正在发生的事情。所以让我们换个话题。
There's also this other element that we need to talk about that makes rest feel bad. And it's the, again, hyper-competitive hamster wheel. of the workplace and of opportunity. And if you're in your 20s, you felt it. This idea of like, oh my goodness, I better work really hard. I cannot switch off because if I do, I'm going to fall behind. There aren't as many opportunities as there were 20 years ago.
还有另一个我们需要讨论的因素，它让休息感觉很糟糕。那就是工作场所和机遇中再次出现的——极度内卷的仓鼠轮。如果你正处于二十几岁，你一定深有体会。这种想法，比如：“哦天哪，我最好拼命工作。我不能放松，因为如果我这么做了，我就会落后。现在的机会可没有20年前那么多了。”
I got to be the one who gets that. You know, the people who are enduring this the most, the sense of competition and this reduction in jobs and this limited opportunities is 20 and 30 somethings. He's a scary fact. A scary fact from an international well-being study published out of Canada found that the most burnt-out generation and the most stressed generation about the future is 18 to 34-year-olds.
我必须成为那个抓住机会的人。你知道，承受这一切最多的人——这种竞争感、工作岗位的减少和有限的机会——正是20多岁和30多岁的人。这是一个可怕的事实。加拿大发表的一项国际福祉研究显示，最精疲力竭的一代、对未来压力最大的一代是18岁至34岁的人群。
98% of them are reporting at least one symptom of burnout. 2% of us are not burnt out. The whole system is building us to make, it's building us. to make us productive and to make us output machines, which is so ironic because a major push behind the rise of AI, which is something that's making us so stressed and the rise of technology was that it was meant to give us more free time and was meant to make our lives easier and more accessible and, you know, give us time off. So why don't we have a four-hour work week?
他们中有98%的人报告至少有一种职业倦怠的症状。只有2%的人没有精疲力竭。整个系统在塑造我们，它在塑造我们
You know, why is everybody even more stressed about getting ahead and about getting stuff done? I feel like it doesn't matter how much free time you have available at this stage. The guilt doesn't go away because it feels like the opportunities are getting smaller and smaller. And that's what's at the base of all of this. We resist actually resting because it makes us feel uncomfortable from a survival lens. If all your life you have been taught that opportunities are fragile, that progress is really easy to lose, that you're only allowed to feel calm when you're ahead, then rest actually feels more dangerous than restorative.
你知道，为什么每个人为了出头和完成任务感到更加焦虑？我觉得在这个阶段，无论你有多少空闲时间，内疚感都不会消失，因为机会似乎越来越少。而这正是这一切的根源。我们抗拒真正的休息，因为从生存的角度来看，这让我们感到不舒服。如果你的整个生活都被灌输这样的观念：机会是脆弱的，进步很容易失去，只有当你领先时你才被允许感到平静，那么休息实际上会感觉比恢复精力更加危险。
Like that's a huge psychological switch up. Like putting your, it honestly feels like sometimes when you rest these days, it's like putting your bag down in a crowded place and like hoping nobody's going to take it. That's what it feels like. Rest feels like giving somebody else an opportunity. Maybe on a more fundamental level as well, I think it's because, again, it's about survival. It's about survival and about the sense of like not dropping the ball.
这真是一个巨大的心理转变。把你的，老实说，有时候在这些天里休息，感觉就像把你的包放在一个拥挤的地方，然后祈祷没有人会拿走它。这就是那种感觉。休息感觉就像是把机会拱手让给别人。或许在更根本的层面上，我也认为这是因为，这同样关乎生存。关乎生存，以及那种“不能掉链子”的感觉。
And then as we've worked harder and rested less, our lives have become emptier. We've ignored a lot of stuff that we probably needed to address. How we've kind of learned that being busy is a form of emotional regulation. It stops us from having to do the uncomfortable inner work that comes with learning to be truly content with who you are. And comes with learning to slow down. and it's deeply psychological here that the social cultural, like these social changes have pushed us into such a hypervigilant stress state that we literally see rest as a threat. And we also see it as something that's going to be really like emotionally revealing, so we avoid it.
然后，随着我们工作更努力、休息更少，我们的生活变得更加空虚。我们忽视了很多可能需要去解决的事情。我们如何逐渐了解到，忙碌是一种情绪调节的形式。它让我们不必去进行那些困难的内心工作——那些学会真正对自我感到满意所伴随的内心工作，以及学会慢下来所伴随的内心工作。这里的心理机制非常深远，社会文化——这些社会变化把我们推入了一种极度警惕的压力状态，以至于我们 literalmente（字面意义上）将休息视为一种威胁。而且我们还认为它会带来很多情绪上的暴露，所以我们选择逃避。
I think if this resonates with you, it's likely that you've been on this high alert for a long time and that you are filling your time with busyness to keep up a sense of functioning. So really, again, this is all coming down to discomfort and how rest is going to allow your mind to relax enough to maybe question some of these life choices, question the system, and also let the anxiety start to creep in because things get a little. little bit calmer. So planning and monitoring and not taking holidays and not taking sick leave gives you something to focus on, which is a lot more pleasant than thinking about bad experiences or thinking about how exhausted you are or thinking about how uncomfortable this is. Rest removes
我想如果这引发了你的共鸣，那很可能是因为你已经处于高度戒备状态很长时间了，你正用忙碌填满时间来维持一种运转感。所以实际上，归根结底，这一切都归结于不适感，以及休息将如何让你的大脑充分放松，从而去质疑其中一些生活选择、质疑这个体制，并让焦虑开始蔓延，因为事情变得稍微平静了一些。因此，计划、监控、不休假和不请病假能给你提供一个专注的焦点，这比去回想糟糕的经历、思考自己有多么筋疲力尽或思考这种感觉有多么不舒服要愉快得多。休息剥夺了
that coping mechanism that has been building up for a while that has been holding you together. So the moment you slow down, like, there's a lot that's going to come with it. There's a lot of memories, worst case scenarios, this vague sense of dread that's going to crop up. And that is the guilt. That is literally the guilt that we are explaining right now. And if every time you experience guilt when you rest, you're going to learn through association, purely through association, like that this is a dangerous thing. And so without even realizing through this associative learning, you're going to, avoid it even more. Okay, we're going to take a short break here, but after this short break,
这种应对机制已经积累了一段时间，它一直在支撑着你。所以当你慢下来的时候，会伴随很多事情涌现。会有很多记忆、最坏的情况预测，以及这种隐隐的不安感悄然浮现。这就是内疚感。这正是我们现在所解释的内疚感。如果每次你休息时感到内疚，你就会通过纯粹的联想在潜意识里学到，这是一件危险的事。因此，甚至在你没有意识到通过这种联想法时，你会更加回避它。好了，我们要在这里稍事休息，但在短暂的休息之后，
we're going to explore the real dangers of this narrative and how we can start to unlearn these toxic, harmful thoughts about rest that we have been sold and we have been told. So, stay with us. 2%. That is the number of people who take the stairs when there is also an escalator available. I'm Michael Easter, and on my podcast, 2%, I break down the science of mental toughness, fitness, and building resilience in our strange modern world. I'll be speaking with writers, researchers, and other health and fitness experts, and more to look past the impractical and way too complex pseudoscience that dominates the wellness industry.
我们将探讨这种叙事方式的真正危险，以及我们如何开始消除这些被灌输给我们的、关于休息的有毒且有害的错误观念。所以，请继续关注我们。百分之二。这就是当旁边有自动扶梯可用时，依然选择走楼梯的人的比例。我是迈克尔·伊斯特，在我的播客“百分之二”中，我将剖析在我们这个奇怪的现代世界中，心理韧性、健身和建立抗压能力的科学。我将与作家、研究人员以及其他健康和健身专家等展开对话，带大家看透主导健康产业的不切实际且过于复杂的伪科学。
We really believe that seed oils were inherently inflammatory. We got it wrong. Many of the problems that we are freaked out about in the world, are the result of stress. Put yourself through some hardships, and you will come out on the other side a happier, more fulfilled, healthier person. Listen to 2%.
我们曾坚信植物油本质上会引起炎症。我们搞错了。我们在世界上感到恐慌的许多问题，其实都是压力的结果。经历一些艰难困苦，你最终会成为一个更快乐、更有成就感、更健康的人。请收听“百分之二”。
That's T-W-O-Persent on the I-Hart Radio app, Apple Podcasts, or wherever you get your podcasts. There's two golden rules that any man should live by. Rule one, never mess with a country girl. You play stupid games, you get stupid prizes. And Rule 2, never mess with her friends either. We always say that trust your girlfriends. I'm Anna Sinfield, and in this new season of the girlfriends...
在iHeart Radio应用程序、Apple Podcasts或您获取播客的任何地方搜索“T-W-O-Percent”。任何男人都应该遵守两条黄金法则。规则一，千万不要惹乡下女孩。玩蠢游戏，就会得到蠢结果。规则二，也千万不要惹她的朋友。我们总是说，要相信你的闺蜜。我是安娜·西恩菲尔德，在这个新一季的“闺蜜”中……
Oh my God, this is the same man. A group of women discover they've all dated the same prolific con artist. I felt like I got hit by a truck. I thought, how could this happen to me? The cops didn't seem to care. So they take matters into their own hands. I said, oh, hell no. I vowed.
哦天哪，这是同一个人。一群女性发现她们都跟同一个惯犯骗手约会过。我感觉像被卡车撞了。我想，这种事怎么会发生在我身上？警察似乎并不在意。所以她们决定自己采取行动。我说，哦，见鬼，绝不。我发誓。
I will be his last target. He's going to get what he deserves. Listen to the girlfriends. Trust me, babe. On the Iheart radio app, Apple Podcasts, or wherever you get your podcasts. You remember when Diana Ross double-tapped Little Kim's boobs at the VMAs?
我将成为他的最后一个目标。他会得到应有的下场。收听“闺蜜”。相信我，宝贝。在iHeart Radio应用程序、Apple Podcasts或您获取播客的任何地方。还记得黛安娜·罗斯在VMA颁奖典礼上拍打莉儿·金的胸部吗？
Or when Kanye said that George Bush didn't like black people. I know what you're thinking. What the hell does George Bush got to do with Little Kim? Well, you can find out on the Look Back at it podcast. I'm Sam Jek. And I'm Alex English. Each episode, we pick a here, unpack what went down and try to make sense of how we survived it.
或者当坎耶说乔治·布什不喜欢黑人时。我知道你在想什么。乔治·布什跟莉儿·金到底有什么关系？嗯，你可以在“Look Back at It”播客中找到答案。我是萨姆·杰克。我是亚历克斯·英格利士。每一集，我们都会挑选一个年份，剖析当时发生的事情，并试着理解我们是如何熬过来的。
Including a recent episode with Mark Lamont Hill waxing all about crack in the 80s. To be clear, 84 is big to me not just because of crack. I'm down to talk about crack all day, but just so y'all know. I mean, at this point, this is the second episode where we've discussed crack. So I'm starting to see that there's a through line. We also have AIDS on the table right now. Thank you finishing that sentence. Yes.
其中包括最近一集与马克·拉蒙特·希尔探讨80年代快克毒品的节目。坦白说，84年对我很重要，不仅仅是因为快克。我随时都能聊快克，只是想让大家知道。我的意思是，此时此刻，这是我们第二集讨论快克。所以我开始发现这里有一条贯穿线。我们现在还讨论了艾滋病。谢谢你把话说完。是的。
I don't think there's a more important year for basketball. black people. Really? Yeah. For me, it's one of the most important years for black people in American history. Listen to look back at it on the IHeart Radio app, Apple Podcasts, or wherever you get your podcasts. Welcome to my new podcast, Learn the Hardway with me, your host, and your favorite therapist, Kear Games. And in recognition of mental health awareness month, I'm bringing over a decade of my own experience in the mental health field and conversations with so many incredible guests. I'm talking, Tripp Fontaine, Ryan Clark. Sometimes when we're in the pursuit of the things, We get so wrapped up in the chase
我认为没有哪一年对黑人篮球来说比这更重要了。真的吗？是的。对我来说，这是美国历史上对黑人最重要的年份之一。在iHeart Radio应用程序、Apple Podcasts或您获取播客的任何地方收听“Look Back at It”。欢迎来到我的新播客“Learn the Hardway”，我是您的主持人、您最喜爱的治疗师吉尔·盖姆斯。为了庆祝心理健康意识月，我带来了自己在心理健康领域十多年的经验，并与许多出色的嘉宾进行了对话。我说的是特里普·方丹、瑞安·克拉克。有时当我们追求某些事物时，
that we don't realize that we are in possession of the thing and we're still chasing it and we don't know when we've done enough because people scoreboard watch. Life becomes about wins and losses. Steve Burns, Dustin Ross, because you find it important to be a good person while you hear on earth
我们太过于投入追逐的过程，以至于没有意识到我们其实已经拥有了它，却还在继续追逐，而且我们不知道什么时候才算够了，因为人们总是盯着记分牌。生活成了关于输赢的较量。史蒂夫·伯恩斯、达斯廷·罗斯，因为你觉得在世期间做一个好人很重要，
or are you a good person because you're afraid? Because that's two different intentions, bro. Absolutely. And that's two different levels of trust. I want you to just really be a good person. Join me, Keer Game, is we have real conversations about healing, growth, fatherhood, pressure, and purpose on my new podcast, Learn the Hardway. Open your free iHeartRadio app, search Learn the Hardway, and listen now.
还是你做一个好人是因为你害怕？因为那是两种不同的动机，兄弟。完全正确。这也是两种不同层次的信任。我希望你能真正地做一个好人。和我一起，吉尔·盖姆斯，在我的新播客“Learn the Hardway”中，就治愈、成长、父爱、压力和目标展开真实的对话。打开免费的iHeartRadio应用程序，搜索“Learn the Hardway”，立即收听。
I kind of feel the need to remind us at this point that rest is literally a biological requirement, the same way that food and water is a biological requirement. You cannot deprive yourself of that. You can push through for a while. You can negotiate your way out of needing rest and needing recovery. You cannot outrun it. It's just not possible. Sleep is like one of the clearest examples we have of this. It's so measurable. So researchers often focus on it as a way of measuring rest.
我想在这个时候提醒大家，休息实际上是一个生理需求，就像食物和水是生理需求一样。你不能剥夺这一点。你可以硬撑一段时间。你可以通过谈判来让自己不需要休息和恢复。你无法逃避它。这是不可能的。睡眠是我们拥有的最清晰的例子之一。它是如此的可测量。所以研究人员经常把它作为衡量休息的一种方式。
Obviously that's not the only way to rest, but researchers at the center of sleep and respiratory neurobiology at the University of Pennsylvania, they conducted a chronic sleep restriction experiment with 48 participants, age 21 to 38. And they basically put them in these, different conditions where they either restricted, rest and sleep to eight hours, six hours, or four hours.
显然，这并不是唯一的休息方式，但宾夕法尼亚大学睡眠和呼吸神经生物学中心的研究人员对48名年龄在21岁到38岁之间的参与者进行了一项长期的睡眠限制实验。他们基本上把这些人置于这些不同的条件下，让他们将休息和睡眠限制在八小时、六小时或四小时。
And this was maintained for two weeks. Then the people either didn't get any sleep for three days or they were allowed to sleep for three days. Honestly, at that point, I'd probably be hallucinating. So I hope these subjects got paid some cash. But what they found was that those who had either four or six hours of sleep a night, their cognitive performance day after day got so bad to the point where their level of impairment was the same as being drunk.
这种情况持续了两周。然后，参与者要么三天不睡觉，要么被允许睡三天觉。说实话，到那个时候，我可能已经开始出现幻觉了。所以我希望这些受试者能拿到一些现金报酬。但他们发现，那些每晚只睡四小时或六小时的人，他们的认知表现日复一日地变得如此糟糕，以至于他们的受损程度和喝醉酒是一样的。
Like, as if they consumed multiple beers, multiple glasses of wine. The scary part is that people often, a lot of these people were like, I don't feel any different. So they walk around and they think, cool, it's okay for me to drive and I'm paying attention at work and I'm paying attention in class and I'm making good decisions. and they're just not because they haven't restored their minds. And again, this is exactly what participants in this study also reported. They found that those who slept for six hours or less were also kind of experiencing this as well. And you remember those people who didn't sleep for three days?
就像他们喝了好几瓶啤酒、好几杯葡萄酒一样。可怕的是，人们经常，许多这样的人会说，我感觉没有任何不同。所以他们四处走动，认为，酷，我开车没问题，我在工作时很专心，我在课堂上很专心，我做出了正确的决定。但事实并非如此，因为他们没有恢复精神。再说一次，这也是这项研究的参与者所报告的情况。他们发现那些睡眠时间为六小时或更少的人也有这种体验。还记得那些三天不睡觉的人吗？
The cumulative effect of sleeping six hours or less five, four hours for two weeks. and not sleeping at all for two days was the same. So that I'm fine feeling, A is a lie, you're not fine, you need to rest. It's also a way of us allowing this habit of like pushing rest down to continue. If you don't feel dramatically worse, you assume you can keep going and going. But what of course, like studies like this are showing us is that you are just pushing the problem further down the line and you've got to pay, you've got to pay the sleep dead eventually. You've got to pay your sleep tax, your rest tax eventually. Now sleep is like the ultimate form of rest. It's like,
连续两周每天睡眠六小时或更少、四小时，以及连续两天完全不睡觉的累积效果是一样的。“我很好”这种感觉，A是个谎言，你并不好，你需要休息。这也是我们允许这种把休息抛在脑后的习惯得以持续的一种方式。如果你没有感觉明显变糟，你就会以为你可以一直坚持下去。但当然，像这样的研究向我们表明，你只是把问题延后了，你迟早要偿还睡眠债务。你迟早要支付睡眠税、休息税。现在睡眠就像是终极形式的休息。就像是，
it's like an emergency maintenance. It's emergency maintenance for your brain. It's consistent maintenance for your brain to clear out clutter, to restore itself from damage, to store memories. And we have a whole episode on the psychology of sleep, if you're interested. But there's also more broader rest that that's needed in your life. Resting, if you want a definition, is like, when you don't have to fix your attention on anything, when your body can unclench and you're not in a state of vigilance or hypervigilance. When you are in a state of vigilance, you are not resting. When you're in a state of alert and attention, you are not resting. That is the state that I'd say the majority of us are in all the time. So when you work for long stretches,
它就像是一次紧急维护。这是对你大脑的紧急维护。这是对你大脑的持续维护，用以清理杂物、从损伤中恢复、储存记忆。如果你感兴趣，我们有一整集专门讲述睡眠心理学的节目。但你的生活中还需要更广泛的休息。如果要给休息下一个定义，那就是，当你不必将注意力集中在任何事情上时，当你的身体可以放松下来，而你不再处于警惕或高度警惕的状态时。当你处于警惕状态时，你并没有在休息。当你处于警觉和专注状态时，你并没有在休息。这就是我可以说我们大多数人一直处于的状态。所以当你长时间工作时，
especially on cognitively demanding tasks, you are spending natural reserves that have built up over time of you build like you're using your natural reserves of attentional control working memory emotional regulation you are taking taking taking you're going to hit zero those systems get tied they get way less efficient that is why you can sit at your laptop for an extra two hours and get less done than when you first started in 20 minutes or if you were to come back you know the next day a 2020 to two, I think, meta-analysis that looked at taking micro-breaks and micro-rests throughout the day. I actually found that this is one of the best things you can do for your well-being.
特别是在需要大量认知任务时，你正在消耗随着时间推移积累下来的自然储备，比如你正在消耗注意力控制、工作记忆、情绪调节的自然储备，你一直在索取索取，直到触底，这些系统变得疲惫，效率大大降低。这就是为什么你可以坐在笔记本电脑前多花两个小时，但做完的事却比你刚开始的20分钟还要少，或者如果你第二天再来做的话。2022年的一项元分析，我想是的，它研究了全天进行微休息和微间歇。我实际上发现这是你可以为自己的健康做的最好的事情之一。
It's going to make you feel so much better, less fatigued, more vigorous. Doing 30 minutes on of work, 10 minutes off, doing an hour on, 20 minutes off, works so well for our brains because it gives us these micro doses of rest that it needs. Your brain is calling, begging. asking you to give it a break. It was not made to sit and stare at a screen for five hours. It was not made to sit and look in an Excel spreadsheet for five hours or Canva for five hours. If you rest, you actually make yourself smarter in a very specific way. And I think this is the important thing because half the reason we don't rest and we don't take breaks and whatever is because we, again, think we're going to fall behind. we think we're going to get less done.
这会让你感觉好得多，疲劳感减少，更有活力。工作30分钟，休息10分钟；工作一小时，休息20分钟，这对我们的大脑非常有效，因为它为我们提供了大脑所需的微剂量休息。你的大脑在呼唤，在乞求。请求你让它休息一下。它不是为了连续坐着盯着屏幕五个小时而创造的。它不是为了连续坐着看Excel表格五个小时或Canva五个小时而创造的。如果你休息，你实际上会以一种非常具体的方式让自己变得更聪明。我认为这是重要的事情，因为我们不休息、不休假等原因的一半是因为我们再次认为我们会落后，我们认为我们会完成更少的工作。
We think we're going to be less efficient. What I'm going to say to you is that if you want to be smarter almost immediately, you have to counterintuitively rest more. And that might sound like a lie. It might sound like a farce, might sound fake. There is so much evidence to this. It's like honestly ridiculous that people don't talk about it more. This is the best example I can give.
我们认为我们的效率会降低。我要对你说的是，如果你想几乎立刻变得更聪明，你必须反直觉地多休息。这听起来可能是个谎言。这听起来可能是一场闹剧，听起来可能是假的。这背后有太多的证据。人们对此讨论得不够，老实说这太荒谬了。这是我能给出的最好的例子。
Have you ever been stuck on a problem? And then you go shower, you go walk, you know, do something unrelated. it and like the answer basically pops into your head. That is a documented effect. That is what rest does for you. Researchers in a 2009 paper found what they call a positive incubation effect when you step away from a problem, when you let your brain rest and then you come back because it allows you to have more open-ended creative thinking.
你是否曾被某个问题难住？然后你去洗澡，去散步，做一些不相关的事情，答案基本上就会突然出现在你的脑海里。这是一个有据可查的效应。这就是休息能为你做的事。研究人员在2009年的一篇论文中发现了他们所称的“正向孵化效应”，即当你从一个问题中抽身出来，当你让你的大脑休息然后回来时，因为它能让你进行更多开放式的创造性思考。
You will literally waste less time by taking time away. You will be able to like rejuvenate, cognitively by not forcing your body and your mind to do these long stretches of productivity. That is one of the easiest and most counterintuitive life hacks you could try today and you would see results. And I think most people won't do it because it seems so contrary to what we've been taught about hard work. So the big question we kind of been running up to this whole time, this whole episode, you and me is how do we actually do it? We know it's important to rest. We can tell it's going to make us smarter. How do we stop the guilt, the guilt from coming in? I have four
通过抽时间休息，你实际上会浪费更少的时间。通过不强迫你的身体和头脑进行长时间的高强度工作，你将能够从认知上恢复活力。这是你可以今天尝试的最简单、最反直觉的生活小窍门之一，而且你会看到效果。我想大多数人不会去做，因为它似乎与我们所学到的关于努力工作的观念背道而驰。所以我们这一整集、你和我一直在探讨的巨大问题是，我们到底该怎么做？我们知道休息很重要。我们可以看出它会让我们变得更聪明。我们如何阻止内疚感、如何阻止内疚感涌入？我有四个
key shifts for you, starting with this one. Stop treating rest like it's a reward. When you treat it like it's a reward, you put it at the mercy of your mood and your to-do list. Your to-do list is designed to win. It's literally endless. If you're a long time overworker, high achiever type, you're a will always find something to do. I know people like you. I am somebody like you. You will always find something to do, even if it is the stupidest thing ever, like clean Tupperware or suddenly decide you're going to do your taxes. If you have an empty space, you're going to take it and you're going to do something productive with it. We can think of as an asset. We can think that it's great. Like, sometimes it's not. The first tip is to start treating rest not as a reward, but as an investment in
关键转变要带给你，从这一点开始。停止把休息当成一种奖励。当你把它当成奖励时，你就把它置于你的情绪和待办事项清单的支配之下。你的待办事项清单旨在获胜。它是无底洞。如果你是一个长期过度工作、追求高成就的人，你的大脑总会找到事情要做。我了解像你这样的人。我就是像你这样的人。你总会找到事情要做，哪怕它是最愚蠢的事，比如清理塑料保鲜盒，或者突然决定去报税。如果你有空白的时间，你就会把它填满，并用它做一些有成效的事。我们可以把时间看作是一项资产。我们可以认为这很好。有时候并非如此。第一个建议是开始把休息不当作奖励，而是当作对未来的投资，
the future and in future you. If you treat rest as an investment like putting money away in a savings account every single week, it becomes part of how you run your life. I say investment because I think the brains of high achievers, overachievers like that language more and how you speak about rest is important. Language towards rest matters, I think, in minimizing guilt initially because it cognitively reframes its importance to you at the beginning. As, I don't know what sounds bad, but as a productivity additive almost. So if you're just trying to firstly just rest without feeling guilty, yes, you can think about it, not as reward.
对未来的你进行投资。如果你把休息当作投资，就像每周往储蓄账户里存钱一样，它就会成为你生活方式的一部分。我之所以说投资，是因为我认为高成就者、过度追求成就者的头脑更喜欢这种语言，而且你谈论休息的方式很重要。我认为，谈论休息时使用的语言在最初尽量减少内疚感方面很重要，因为它在开始时从认知上重新构建了它对你的重要性。作为一种，我不知道什么听起来不太好，但几乎就像是一个生产力的添加剂。所以如果你首先只是想在不感到内疚的情况下休息，是的，你可以这样想，不要把它当作奖励。
You can also think about it as an investment in you. And that, I think, changes your emotions towards it. It's not something you do when you're good enough. It's not something you do because you deserve it. You do it because it's like maintenance. You are building a successful life. It is a non-negotiable. It is a smart non-negotiable.
你也可以把它当作对你自己的投资。我认为，这改变了你对它的情感。这不是当你表现足够好时才做的事。这不是因为你应得的才去做。你这样做是因为它就像是维护。你正在建立一个成功的生活。这是一个不容协商的事项。这是一个明智的非妥协事项。
The second cognitive shift is to think of rest as being as natural as the seasons. When you rest, you are honoring the small winters of your life. And you can't have the summers and the springs without the winters. Rest is as important as the seasons are to Earth and you're part of Earth. and feeling that it's really sinking into how natural it is to honor that and to honor the system and to not disturb the system by honoring the seasons of life has like really helped me, I think, in such an important way. Basically, how I've started to think of it is that some parts of life, like I said, are summer.
第二个认知转变是把休息看作和四季一样自然。当你休息时，你是在致敬你生活中的小小冬天。没有冬天，就不会有夏天和春天。休息和四季对地球一样重要，而你也是地球的一部分。这种感觉真正深入骨髓，体会到顺应自然是多么自然的事，去尊重这个系统，不通过破坏生活的季节来扰乱这个系统，这在很大程度上真正帮助了我。基本上，我开始这样认为：生活的一些部分，正如我所说，是夏天。
There are going to be natural seasons where I grow, I expand, I am full of light and energy I am up all the time. There's autumn that's like the shedding. There's spring. that's the work, and you have to have the winters. You have to have periods of hibernation and rest and just preparing for the next season. Every single cycle in your life requires a winter. You require consolidation, you require rest to be able to keep going. The problem is, is that we often demand summer output across all seasons, especially in our winter seasons. And I'm not actually talking about seasons here. I'm talking metaphorically, but, you know, we treat ourselves like a machine
生命中总会有自然的季节，我会成长，我会扩展，我充满光芒和能量，我总是精力充沛。秋天就像是脱落。春天就是播种，而你必须经历冬天。你必须经历蛰伏、休息的时期，并为下一个季节做准备。你生命中的每一个周期都需要一个冬天。你需要整合，你需要休息才能继续前进。问题在于，我们常常在所有季节都要求夏日般的产出，尤其是在我们的冬天。我其实并不是在谈论自然界的季节。我在用隐喻，但是，你知道的，我们像对待机器一样对待自己
where the setting is going to stay the same the whole year round. Humans simply do not work like that. Like, the cycles that the earth operates on and that you operate on are incredibly important and designed to make you the best version of yourself and designed to be the system that you work on. Just because you have stuff to do doesn't mean you can override nature. It doesn't mean you can override your natural settings. So if you want your physical health, your mental health to be great, to be amazing, your cognitive health to be amazing, you have to acknowledge that there are so many factors that are going to contribute to when you are going to be forced to rest and when you are going to be able to be productive, you will be more productive if you follow.
设置整年都保持不变。人类根本不是那样运作的。就像地球运转所依赖的周期以及你运转所依赖的周期一样，它们极其重要，旨在让你成为最好的自己，并被设计成适合你运作的系统。仅仅因为你有事要做，并不意味着你可以凌驾于自然之上。这并不意味着你可以凌驾于你的自然设定之上。因此，如果你希望你的身体健康、心理健康保持极佳、令人惊叹，你的认知健康令人惊叹，你必须承认，有太多因素会决定你什么时候被迫休息，什么时候能够保持高产，如果你遵循这些规律，你会更有生产力。
What is it like naturally set for your humanness? And what is the, naturally set for your body and for your mind. Now, here is the unsexy part that makes all of this actionable. Throughout all this, these tips, you actually need to start scheduling rest. Like I said, like it's a non-negotiable. You cannot wait for it to naturally happen because you'll usually end up resting when you're sick. So it's just about recovery, not about deep nourishment. I want you to look at your to-do list right now. And I want you to look at your do list right now. And I want you to look at your diary and I want you to plan one day a week, one afternoon a week where you don't do anything as your scheduled rest day. I like to do this thing with my friends on Sunday mornings
什么是为你的属人性自然设定的？什么是为你的身体和心灵自然设定的？现在，这是让这一切变得切实可行却又不够性感的部分。在所有这些技巧中，你实际上需要开始安排休息。就像我说的，这就像是一个不可妥协的条件。你不能等待它自然发生，因为你通常最终只有在生病时才会休息。所以这只是关于恢复，而不是关于深层的滋养。我希望你现在看看你的待办事项清单。我希望你现在看看你的做事清单。我希望你看看你的日程表，并计划每周抽出一天、每周抽出一个下午，什么也不做，作为你预定的休息日。我喜欢在周日早晨和我的朋友们做这件事
called the dilly dally. This is my rest. This is how I like really restore my mind and like allow me. I hate saying the word allow but like help myself get into it where me and my friends I live for my dilly dally days. We all get together on a Sunday. We pick each other up, phones down, and we just potter along. We go to the markets. We get a coffee. We walk around the grocery store. When we come together, like we don't have any plans. We don't have any plans. We don't have any agenda. We just get to do whatever we want. We dilly and we dally. And that's a non-negotiable for me. And I used to not have those things in my diary. I used to want to keep as much time open to be productive and to work and to do the podcast and whatever and like now I know that that is an investment that is my
叫做闲逛。这是我的休息。这就是我如何真正恢复心灵并允许自己的方式。我讨厌用“允许”这个词，但就像是帮助自己进入那种状态一样，我和我的朋友们——我为了我的闲逛日而活。我们周日聚在一起。我们去接彼此，放下手机，我们就这样慢悠悠地闲逛。我们去集市。我们买杯咖啡。我们在杂货店里走走。当我们聚在一起时，我们没有任何计划。我们没有任何计划。我们没有任何议程。我们只是做任何我们想做的事。我们东拉西扯，无所事事。这对我来说是不可妥协的。我过去在日程表里没有这些安排。我过去想尽可能多地留出时间来保持高效、工作、做播客或者别的什么，而现在我知道那是一项投资，那是我的
time that is something that I do for myself the final tip of the day I actually have some homework for you you can schedule rest we can do all these things but there is an expert on this who I just think is incredible and it's a book I'm putting on the psychology of your 20 syllabus called laziness does not exist and this is a concept that I want us to get like drill into our brain. This is a book by Devin Price. It was gifted to me, ironically, by my family. So they were definitely trying to send me some not so subtle hints, but I adored this book and I adored the theme. And there was one section of it that stood out to me, which is that calling someone lazy or calling yourself lazy is a moral judgment, not a diagnosis,
时间，那是我为自己做的事。今天的最后一个技巧，我其实给你们留了点作业，你可以安排休息，我们可以做所有这些事情，但关于这个话题有一位专家，我认为他简直不可思议，这是一本我放进你的二十岁心理学大纲里的书，叫做《懒惰并不存在》，这是我想让我们的大脑深入理解的一个概念。这是德文·普莱斯（Devin Price）写的一本书。讽刺的是，这本书是我家人送给我的礼物。所以他们绝对是在试图给我一些不太含蓄的暗示，但我非常喜欢这本书，我也非常喜欢这个主题。其中有一部分让我印象深刻，那就是：称呼某人为懒惰或称呼自己为懒惰是一种道德判断，而不是一种诊断，
and moral judgments, social judgments change. It is a socially constructed insult that is applied selectively. This is what this author says. He's like, when you call somebody lazy, we apply that selectively to disabled people, chronically ill people, neurodivergent people, poor people and marginalized groups when, you know, when they resist overwork, when they remember their limits. Like before we were talking about this, you know, expectations around, productivity are deeply unequal.
而且道德判断、社会判断是会改变的。这是一种社会构建的侮辱，被有选择地应用。这就是这位作者所说的。他说，当你称某人懒惰时，我们会把这个词有选择地应用在残疾人、慢性病患者、神经多样性人群、穷人和边缘化群体身上，你知道的，当他们抵制过度工作、当他们谨记自己的极限时。就像我们之前谈论的那样，你知道的，围绕生产力的期望是极度不平等的。
Like when somebody who's rich and famous works really hard, we're like hustler. So good. Like they're so motivated. When somebody who's poor works really hard, it's like, why are you neglecting your children? Like, what is wrong with you? Some people are praised for rest and for having boundaries.
比如，当一个富有且有名的人非常努力工作时，我们会说：‘真是个拼命三郎。太棒了。’就像他们多有动力一样。当一个穷人非常努力工作时，就会变成：‘你为什么忽视你的孩子？’或者‘你有什么毛病？’有些人因为休息和设立界限而受到赞扬。
Others are punished for the same behaviors. The myth of laziness that I want to finish. is basically like this is a tool to make people feel bad in order to reward others and in order to work harder for others. When you separate yourself from those narratives, when you realize laziness doesn't exist, that's just a moral judgment, you get to live life the way it was really intended. Honouring the winters. Honoring the down times. Doing what is needed and not excess stuff that isn't. And in that way you really experience huge. productivity in a much more nourishing way, in a way that is sustainable. Sure, you might have
而其他人则因同样的行径而受到惩罚。我想结束的关于懒惰的神话，基本上就像是：这是一种让人感到糟糕的工具，目的是奖励其他人，并让人为了其他人而更加努力工作。当你将自己从这些叙事中抽离出来，当你意识到懒惰并不存在，那只是一种道德判断，你就能按照原本真正意图的方式生活。尊重冬天。尊重低谷期。做需要做的事情，而不是那些不需要的过头事。通过这种方式，你真的能以一种更有滋养的方式、一种可持续的方式体验到巨大的生产力。当然，你可能拥有
less output. Sure, you might lose the competitive edge. But when you shift into this mindset, like, the things that you were competing for, you don't really care anymore because you realize, like, if I had to give up all that makes me human for this and all that was enjoyable to have this, what's the point? I work so hard so I can have an enjoyable life. But if I didn't work hard right now I'd have an enjoyable life anyways. Like, that's really the thing I want to end on. That's what I'm hoping you take away from this episode. Like, the guilt you feel may not feel optional right now, but it is entirely socially conditioned.
较少的产出。当然，你可能会失去竞争优势。但当你转变成这种心态时，你会发现，你曾经争夺的东西，你其实已经不在乎了，因为你意识到：‘如果为了这个，我必须放弃所有让我成为人的东西以及所有享受生活的乐趣，那还有什么意义？’我如此努力工作，是为了能过上享受的生活。但如果我此刻不努力工作，我无论如何也能过上享受的生活。这真的是我想以此结语的事情。这就是我希望你从这集节目中带走的东西。那种负罪感现在可能让你觉得无法避免，但它完全是社会条件反射的产物。
You have no reason to feel guilty for rest. Your ancestors didn't feel guilty for rest because they knew it was necessary. It doesn't make you a bad person. It is also not suddenly going to undo hours and hours of hard work. Think about Simone Biles. Like, best time. athlete of all time. She literally took two years off and she came back and won a bunch of gold medals. It is an essential ingredient that you cannot neglect and it is something that I think really incredible
你没有任何理由为休息感到内疚。你的祖先休息时并没有感到内疚，因为他们知道这是必须的。这不会让你成为一个坏人。它也不会突然抹杀成百上千个小时的辛勤工作。想想西蒙娜·拜尔斯（Simone Biles）。就像史上最伟大的运动员一样。她literally休息了两年，然后回归并赢得了一堆金牌。这是一个你不可忽视的必不可少的要素，我认为这是真正不可思议的、
successful people have learned how to master and learn how to honor. You need to be one of those people. So if you've made it this far, thank you for sticking around. You have made it to our secret part of the episode where I give you an emoji to comment below to prove that you made it to the end. Our emoji for today is a little cloud. I think that's a nice rest symbol. I appreciate you listening to the whole episode. I hope the message rings loud and clear in your mind the next time you want to take a day off the next time you find yourself sitting on the couch with nothing to do. Here is your permission slip.
成功人士已经学会掌握并学会尊重的事情。你需要成为这样的人。所以，如果你听到了这里，谢谢你的坚持。你已经来到了我们播客的神秘部分，在这里我给你一个表情符号，让你在下方评论，以证明你听到了最后。我们今天的表情符号是一朵小云。我认为这是一个很好的休息象征。我很感激你收听完整期节目。我希望下次你想请假一天时，下次你发现自己无所事事地坐在沙发上时，这个信息能在你脑海中清晰响亮地回荡。这是给你的通行证。
You are allowed to do that. As always, thank you to our researcher Libby Colbert for her contributions to this episode. She is incredible. And until next time, stay safe, be kind, be gentle to yourself. we will talk very, very soon. 2%. That is the number of people who take the stairs when there is also an escalator available.
你被允许这么做。一如既往，感谢我们的研究员莉比·科尔伯特（Libby Colbert）对本期节目的贡献。她太不可思议了。直到下一次，注意安全，保持善良，对自己温柔一点，我们很快很快就会再聊。2%。这就是当有自动扶梯可用时，仍然选择走楼梯的人所占的比例。
I'm Michael Easter, and on my podcast, 2%, I break down the science of mental toughness, fitness, and building resilience in our strange modern world. I'll be speaking with writers, researchers, and other health and fitness experts, and more to look past the impractical and way too complex pseudoscience
我是迈克尔·伊斯特（Michael Easter），在我的播客节目《2%》中，我将剖析精神韧性、健身的科学，以及在我们这个奇怪的现代世界中建立复原力的法则。我将与作家、研究人员以及其他健康和健身专家等进行对话，超越那些主导健康产业的不切实际且过于复杂的伪科学。
that dominates the wellness industry. We really believe that seed oils were inherently inflammatory. We got it wrong. Many of the problems that we are freaked out about in the world are the result of stress. Put yourself through some hardships, and you will come out on the other side a happier, more fulfilled, healthier person.
我们真的曾相信种子油天生具有炎症性。我们弄错了。我们在世界上感到恐慌的许多问题都是压力的结果。让自己经历一些苦难，你就会在另一端成为一个更快乐、更满足、更健康的人。
Listen to 2%. That's T-W-O-Persent on the I-Hart Radio app, Apple Podcasts, or wherever you get your podcasts. There's two golden rules that any man should live by. Rule one, never mess with a country girl. You play stupid games, you get stupid prizes. And rule two, never mess with her friends either. We always say that, trust your girlfriends.
收听《2%》。也就是 Apple Podcasts、iHeartRadio App 或你获取播客的任何地方的 T-W-O-P-E-R-C-E-N-T。任何男人都应该遵守两条黄金法则。规则一，永远不要惹乡下女孩。你玩愚蠢的游戏，就会得到愚蠢的奖品。规则二，也永远不要惹她的朋友。我们总是这么说，相信你的女朋友们。
I'm Anna Sinfield, and in this new season of the girlfriends... Oh my God, this is the same man. A group of women discover they've all dated the same prolific con artist. I felt like I got hit by a truck. I thought, how could this happen to me? The cops didn't seem to care. So they take matters into their own hands. I said, oh, hell no.
我是安娜·辛菲尔德（Anna Sinfield），在《女朋友们》的这个新季节里……天哪，这是同一个人。一群女性发现她们都和同一个多产的骗子约会过。我感觉自己像被卡车撞了。我想，这种事怎么会发生在我身上？警察似乎并不在乎。于是她们开始自己动手。我说，噢，见鬼，绝不。
I vowed, I will be his last target. He's going to get what he deserves. Listen to the girlfriends. Trust me, babe. On the Iheart radio app, Apple Podcasts, or wherever you get your podcasts. Do you remember when Diana Ross double-tapped Little Kim's boobs at the VMAs? Or when Kanye said that George Bush didn't like black people.
我发誓，我将成为他的最后一个目标。他会得到应有的惩罚。收听《女朋友们》。相信我，宝贝。在 iHeartRadio App、Apple Podcasts 或你获取播客的任何地方收听。你还记得黛安娜·罗斯（Diana Ross）在 VMA 上双击小金（Lil' Kim）的胸部吗？或者当坎耶（Kanye）说乔治·布什（George Bush）不喜欢黑人时。
I know what you're thinking. What the hell does George Bush got to do a little kill? Well, you can find out on the Look Back at it podcast. I'm Sam J. And I'm Alex English. Each episode, we pick it here, unpack what went down, and try to make sense of how we survived it. Including a recent episode with Mark Lamont Hill,
我知道你在想什么。乔治·布什跟小金到底有什么关系？好吧，你可以在《Look Back at It》播客中找到答案。我是山姆·J（Sam J.）。我是亚历克斯·英格利士（Alex English）。每集节目中，我们都会挑选一个年份，剖析当时发生了什么，并试图弄清楚我们是如何挺过来的。包括最近一期邀请马克·拉蒙特·希尔（Marc Lamont Hill）的节目，
waxing all about crack in the 80s. To be clear, 84 is big to me, not just because of crack. I'm down to talk about crack on day, but just so y'all know. I mean, at this point, Mark, this is the second episode where we've discussed. That's correct. So I'm starting to see that there's a through line. We also have AIDS on the table right now. Now you're finishing that sentence.
大谈80年代的可卡因。澄清一下，84年对我很重要，不仅仅是因为可卡因。我随时准备聊聊关于可卡因的事，只是想让你们知道。我的意思是，马克，在这一点上，这是我们讨论的第二集了。没错。所以我开始看到一条主线了。我们现在还把艾滋病摆在了台面上。现在你把那句话说完了。
Yes. I don't think there's a more important year for black people. Really? Yeah. For me, it's one of the most important years for black people in American history. Listen to look back at it on the IHeart Radio app, Apple Podcasts, or wherever you get your podcasts. Welcome to my new podcast, Learn the Hard Way with me, your host, and your favorite therapist, Kear Games. And in recognition of mental health awareness month,
是的。我认为没有比这更重要的一年了，对于黑人而言。真的吗？是的。对我来说，这是美国历史上对黑人而言最重要的年份之一。在 iHeartRadio App、Apple Podcasts 或你获取播客的任何地方收听《Look Back at It》。欢迎来到我的新播客《硬核领悟》（Learn the Hard Way），我是你的主持人、你最喜欢的治疗师基尔·盖恩斯（Kear Gaines）。为了庆祝心理健康意识月，
I'm bringing over a decade of my own experience in the mental health field and conversations with so many incredible guests. I'm talking. Tripp Fontaine, Ryan Clark. Sometimes when we're in the pursuit of the thing, we get so wrapped up in the chase that we don't realize that we are in possession of the thing
我带来了我在心理健康领域十多年的经验，以及与众多不可思议的嘉宾的对话。我说的是。特里普·方丹（Tripp Fontaine）、瑞安·克拉克（Ryan Clark）。有时，当我们追求某样东西时，我们太深陷于追逐之中，以至于没有意识到我们已经拥有了这样东西，
and we're still chasing it and we don't know when we've done enough because people scoreboard watch. Life becomes about wins and losses. Steve Burns, Dustin Ross, you find it important to be a good person while you hear on earth? Are you a good person because you're afraid? Because that's two different intentions, bro.
我们却还在追逐，并且我们不知道什么时候才算足够，因为人们总是在盯着记分牌看。生活变成了关于输赢。史蒂夫·伯恩斯（Steve Burns）、达斯汀·罗斯（Dustin Ross），你觉得作为一个在世的人，做一个好人很重要吗？你是一个好人是因为你害怕吗？因为那是两种不同的意图，兄弟。
Absolutely. And that's two different levels of trust. I want you to just really be a good person. Join me, Kear Gaines, is we have real conversations about healing, growth, fatherhood, pressure, and purpose on my new podcast, Learn the Hardway. Open your free, our heart radio app. Search Learn the Hardway and listen now. There aren't comments yet for this episode. Click on any sentence in the transcript to leave a comment.
绝对的。那是两个不同层面的信任。我希望你能真正地做一个好人。加入我，基尔·盖恩斯，我们将在我的新播客《硬核领悟》中就疗愈、成长、父道、压力和目标展开真实的对话。打开你免费的 iHeartRadio App。搜索《Learn the Hard Way》并立即收听。本集暂无评论。点击文字记录中的任意句子即可发表评论。